le col delle le comité opérationnel de
lutte contre la délinquance
environnementale on en parle ce matin
dans son caddie avec renaud gaudeul
bonjour bonjour au novotel procureur de
la république qui copréside ce golden
avec le préfet de martinique
il s'agit en fait renaud gaudeul depuis
la fin du mois de février de veiller au
respect direct de environnement en des
règles environnementales dans notre île
et on peut dire qu'il y a du boulot sur
google oui vous avez parfaitement raison
et c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle nous avons pris l'initiative de
créer ce nouveau comité comité
opérationnel de lutte contre la
délinquance environnementale qui est une
initiative totalement locale c'est à
dire qu'en l'occurrence la martinique en
l'occurrence est vraiment en avance sur
ce point là puisque c'est un comité
encore une fois qu'il n'existe nulle
part ailleurs
mais les enjeux ici nous paraissent
tellement important et disons le c'est
clairement le retard pris dans ce
domaine là et qui est également de toute
évidence est une évidence et ce qui a
justifié dans l'occurrence eh bien on
décide de franchir un pas supplémentaire
et d'agir encore beaucoup plus
rapidement dans ce domaine alors comment
ça fonctionne ça veut dire que ce comité
va s'autosaisir sur des problématiques
comme le les véhicules hors d'usagé on
va approfondir cela dans quelques
secondes mais c'est quelqu'un qui vous
alerte ou bien c'est vous qui vous auto
saisissez les deux ça peut être
effectivement donc par exemple des
citoyens qui nous alerte sur telle ou
telle problématique ça peut être
également et c'est quand même la voir en
principe naturel les administrations qui
oeuvrent dans ce domaine là et qui nous
alerte sur tel ou tel sujet qui devient
véritablement problématique ici en
martinique et ça peut être également
effectivement des sujets dont nous auto
saisi son qui composent ce comité avec
quels moyens et vous disposez de quels
moyens pour pouvoir agir alors en
l'occurrence donc le comité comme velin
guillet tout à l'heure coprésidée par
moi même et par le préfet et nous avons
à l'intérieur de ce comité un nombre
très important de d'administration qui
participent et qui sont toutes qui
oeuvrent tout dans ce domaine là ça peut
être le fait sachant que des défauts rsa
peut être évidemment en premier lieu la
des halles qui a pour mission première
de une des missions essentielles de
lutter contre ces atteintes à
l'environnement
nous avons également naturellement les
forces de police et de gendarmerie nous
avons le parc naturel régional nous
avons
transversale ça sera absolument
transversale et toutes ces
administrations donc participent d'ores
et déjà de manière active à l'intérieur
de ceux de ce golden et en l'occurrence
et bien ce kolda a pour mission
d'impulser une véritable dynamique pour
que toutes ces administrations la
travaillent conjointement une première
sortie du col den sur la thématique des
vh eu des véhicules hors d'usagé vhu est
rendu au gros morne sur le site de
plusieurs garages pour y constater non
seulement des atteintes à
l'environnement et d'autres types
d'effraction et la suite tous les
contrevenants se fera quoi alors et bien
en l'occurrence ce sera des sanctions
qui seront prises contre ces en
l'occurrence donc ses propriétaires qui
ne respectaient absolument pas la
législation notamment en matière de deux
véhicules hors d'usagé qui doivent être
traités par une seule filière bien
particulière je crois qu'en l'occurrence
il y a cette lutte contre les véhicules
hors d'usagé est une est une est une
évidence je crois que là nous sommes à
une heure où tout le monde si on en
croit serge letchimy de pied d'abord
signer qui a qui a rappelé au préfet qui
copréside ce col des mecs c'est à lui
d'actionner maintenant tous les leviers
pour que les 15000 vh recensés dans
l'île disparaissent de notre champ
visuel mais absolument parce que quand
je dis c'est une évidence c'est à dire
qu'en l'occurrence il suffit d'aller sur
nos routes
ici en martinique encore une fois nous
sommes à une heure où beaucoup de
badauds de nos concitoyens sont sur les
routes
et j'imagine que ça fait bien longtemps
qu'il ne compte plus le nombre de vh et
qu'il croise en se rendant au travail
je pense également lorsqu'il suffit
d'aller en commune le week-end par
exemple et d'aller se balader dans l'est
dans la campagne pour se rendre compte
de ce que on a des vertus qui sont
stockés fa qui sont stockés qui sont
réalité abondonner qui sont qui sont
jetés parfois et même souvent au fond de
ravines et qui a un nom avec un nombre
qui est quand même extrêmement élevé on
sait de la juge donc c'est le constat
sur le constat je crois qu'il ya une
évidence après sur les méthodes pour
lutter contre cela il là nous devons
impérativement progresser et c'est ce
que nous proposons de faire notamment
mais pas seulement notamment au sein du
col d'eze en vous écoutant ce matin qui
doit à vera qui doit avoir peur c'est
par exemple moi qui abandonne son
véhicule sur le bas côté du chemin en me
disant ah ben voilà je m'en suis
débarrassé pro finale est-ce que je dois
avoir peur
parce qu'on peut retrouver les personnes
qui abandonnent les véhicules et c'est
exactement cela
en l'occurrence le l'objectif c'est de
dire et puis il ya un plan il ya un plan
qui effectivement qu'il est gay mais qui
est menée et qui est là pour donc
traiter le un nombre donc déterminé donc
de véhicules hors d'usagé des vh eu tous
les ans et pourpre et faire en sorte
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient éliminés
comme il se doit
mais si on ne fait que ça on n'avancera
pas on n'avancera pas civilisation c'est
fini on passe maintenant à la phase de
répression absolument c'est à dire en
l'occurrence de dire il faut évidemment
et évidemment sur sur ce plan là et
faire en sorte que nous ayons donc tous
ces véhicules que l'on retrouvait pour
lequel on ne retrouve plus parce qu'ils
sont donnés depuis très longtemps on ne
retrouve plus les propriétaires bon
effectivement il faut les traiter cette
manière là mais en revanche je constate
d'ailleurs plus vous ramassez de vh et
dans certains lieux et plus vous en
retrouver dans la semaine qui suit est
par conséquent en l'occurrence ça veut
bien dire que nous avons des délais
courts des quelques concitoyens qui
estime qu'en l'occurrence ils n'ont pas
à respecter leurs obligations dans ce
domaine et qui eux continuent à
alimenter cv à celle que l'on retrouve
ainsi sur le domaine public ou alors sur
des 2 sur les terrains privés
et c'est contre ce type de phénomène là
qu'il faut agir il faut agir en
l'occurrence en disant non on ne peut
pas continuer comme cela vous avez une
obligation
l'obligation elle est quand même pas
très compliqué l'obligation c'est celle
simplement d'aller ramener son voeu a
chu dans un centre dans un des quatre
centres agréés qui existent ici en
martinique
c'est la seule obligation qui existe
pour ces personnes-là
donc soit le fond tant mieux et c'est
quand même me semble-t-il la voie
normale soit elles le font pas et non
seulement on le fera pour eux mais on
leur présentera la facture et il y aura
également des sanctions supplémentaires
pourquoi avoir choisi le gone parce
qu'on aurait pu retrouver au
saint-esprit au vauclin abbas prêtes à
n'importe où mais bien sûr mais il faut
commencer quelque part et en
l'occurrence ces gros monde mais je
dirais c'est très franchement c'est
quasiment le hasard qui a voulu que ce
soit le gros mot qui nous selon
l'endroit où nous avons commencé mais
ces opérations là vont se poursuivre
elle est certainement pas unique cette
opération là elle va se poursuivre dans
les dents les semaines dans les mois à
venir alors on pourra pas tout les
médiatisé mais il va y en avoir encore
un nombre très important
et là aussi je crois que le message doit
être clair soit les détenteurs de ces
épaves là et notamment de ses garages
plus ou moins plus ou moins en situation
licite
soit elles se mettent aux normes soient
elles règlent la situation très
rapidement et en mieux et il n'y aura
pas de poursuites soient elles ne font
rien et à ce moment là ce sont les
services de police et gendarmerie
appuyée par les administrations qui
interviendront et qui par conséquent
récupéreront certes ces véhicules là
mais présenteront la facture et avec des
poursuites pénales qui seront également
engagés qu'entendez vous par la
protection de l'environnement n'y a pas
que les hug également nos compatriotes
qui se débarrassent de leur
réfrigirateur de leur cuisinière est ce
que ça peut être par exemple ces
panneaux publicitaires qui pullulent sur
le bas côté du chemin et qui présente
des dangers avec le vent par exemple là
aussi vous pouvez intervenir
ça fait partie effectivement des sujets
dont nous pouvons nous emparer je vous
fous très franchement parce que la wii
c'est un sujet pour lequel je vais être
franc on n'a pas fixé à palinges
williams sur le yart et absolue parce
qu'il y en a beaucoup d'autres
mais rien n'empêche effectivement de le
mettre dans les priorités et encore une
fois c'est pas parce que l'on ne met pas
une priorité qui ne cela ne veut pas
dire que l'on agisse vite nous avons en
nous avons en l'occurrence des domaines
extrêmement vaste en matière
d'environnement
je pense par exemple à toutes ces
constructions qui sont enquis qui sont
réalisés en divers lieux sur le
territoire et qui sont construire en
toute illégalité
par exemple nous avons tous me tendez la
perche pour l'actualité vous avez une
maison qui était détruite ya pas
longtemps françois et certaines
associations se plaignent que à côté
d'autres maisons avec des personnes
peut-être plus nantis ont pu construire
également toute illégalité vous pourriez
intervenir là dessus au que oui oh que
oui en l'occurrence elles doivent
trembler ces personnes plus nantis qui
ont pu construire sur le littoral est
encore heureux
et encore que cette appli cette liste
nationale s'applique s'agissant de toute
personne et je dirais même peut être
d'ailleurs avoir une protection sans
pardon sans aucune protection à valeur
d'admirer la moine et l'a montré la voir
les autres relations mais alors je peux
vous dire qu'en tout cas certainement
pas au niveau de la justice et en
l'occurrence à chaque fois que nous
aurons saisis nous agirons
très clairement et ça je crois que le
message doit être plus que clair il n'y
a strictement aucune où il ne pourrait y
avoir aucune différenciation en fonction
de la fortune plus ou moins importante
des personnes
ça me paraît d'une telle évidence que je
suis même avec l'ours yoghi composition
vous serez attendus au détour là et bien
je serai je serai présent rendez vous
pouvez faire confiance
vous avez parlé de fonctionnement
transversale mais cette protection de
l'environnement et du et du respect de
la législation par quand même demandé
beaucoup d'efforts en continu vous avez
vraiment les moyens de ça alors ce que
je constate ici c'est que en réalité le
nombre de l'administration et le nombre
de personnes qui agissent sur le terrain
dans le domaine environnement est élevé
donc je crois sincèrement que ce n'est
pas une question de moyens
en revanche ce qui se produit c'est que
nous avons un certain nombre
d'administrations qui agissent mais
chacune de leur côté
j'ai des exemples très concrets où nous
avons des sur une même situation
plusieurs administrations qui avait
relevé des infractions par exemple sur
une habitation construite sur un terrain
inondable ou qui la compétence de
plusieurs de de plusieurs
administrations différentes et donc ses
différentes administrations qui agissent
mais sans savoir même qui en a une autre
qui agit et par conséquent de ce point
de vue là on n'est pas efficace parce
que si chacun agit de son côté
malheureusement on voit bien que or le
résultat n'est pas au rendez vous donc
l'idée en l'occurrence est de faire en
sorte qu'ils aient une meilleure
coordination entre ces différentes
administrations et je crois que là nous
agirons de manière beaucoup plus
efficace
la deuxième chose c'est que on se rend
compte que très souvent eh bien on a
d'une part l'action administrative
d'autre part l'action pénale et là aussi
s'il n'y a pas de coordination on
n'arrive pas beaucoup de résultats
donc l'idée c'est d'avoir une meilleure
une meilleure coordination dans ce
domaine merci renaud gaudeul qui
copréside le col delle le comité
opérationnel de lutte contre la
délinquance environnementale bonne
journée
[Musique]